turn now to south africa to speak to our
correspondent john sparks who is in
johannesburg where deadly riots are
continuing
john for those of us those just joining
us
just remind us what is happening in the
background to it
sure yes i mean we have seen three days
of
protesting of a rioting of general
lawlessness
in some of the biggest cities in
south africa and that was triggered by
the arrest of the former president of
this country
jacob zuma he was arrested on thursday
night he handed himself
over to police after much after much
drama um
to the police after the constitutional
court
in this country um sentenced him for
15 months for his refusal to attend a
anti-corruption commission called the
zonder commission and the irony here is
that
president zuma initiated or set up that
that commission when he was president he
was forced to do so because of the
widespread allegations of corruption and
graft what they call
state capture in this country which he
attracted and people
in his circle attracted as well in
particular a family an indian family
called the
the guptas who moved to south africa
during his time
and are accused of wasting
stealing huge amount of state resources
we're back up now
we're walking up uh watt street in
alexandra one of the largest townships
in johannesburg
with members of the south african police
service
they have been involved in running
skirmishes
with with residents and others
protesters
looters through much of the day i think
you can see
a shopping mall the pan africa shopping
mall just behind them
that was invaded essentially yesterday
at 6 p.m
it's a shopping mall that you would
recognize at home with all of the
same sorts of shops except everything
has been stripped
now everything has been taken out
including the furniture
the cash machines anything of value
what the police have been trying to do
is
restore a sense of order in the central
business district but they are
completely outnumbered completely
overwhelmed
they've been using rubber bullets to
drive people back but as soon as they do
so
people come forward again in this very
repetitive
process that the police really are not
able to control
at all and we have now heard that the
south african military the south african
defense force
will be deployed on the streets and
frankly
they're going to have to do that because
this sort of
scene has been replicated all over the
country
in towns and cities all over the country
it's really
a really nasty episode of lawlessness
although
it has been applauded by some applauded
by members of jacob zuma's
family who seem to think that this is a
an exercise in political demonstration
uh
a a sign of support for their
father but i think they are in the
minority those people
just just looking behind us just to see
what people are doing
you can see a few people they're
having a look coming out of shops seeing
if there's anything else they can
they can take and really there's not
much the police can do
at this stage they're just not here in
in the numbers to
enforce any sort of order and
you know it's it's obviously a tragedy
for the people who own these businesses
who work here
i'm talking about thousands of people
who would who would work here
because everything is is gone they will
be starting from
from scratch but a very very difficult
situation for the
for the police here to to contain but i
do think
the police are going to start moving up
wall street again and we'll just
we'll just follow them from a distance
i think it's important to say that
the unemployment rate in south africa is
very high
covet has been really tough for people
we're in the middle of a
nasty third wave of infection with high
levels of restrictions now
in place in the country and people
are hungry you know this is a developing
world country
people are frustrated and angry and
the arrest of jacob zuma and the the
initial protests i've seen some people
throwing some bottles and stones now
and someone over there carrying a couch
probably
probably removed from a from a shop
people are taking the opportunity
to enrich themselves while they can
but again this is the result i mean this
is the center of alexandra
prosperous prosperous uh shopping
precinct that now looks like it's been
the scene
of a nasty war it's really difficult
really difficult for
the south african authorities to get a
hold of this and it symbolizes this
nasty factional dispute within the
ruling anc
party the president south africa cyril
ramaphosa was on television last night
saying that episodes like this the
violence was completely
uh unacceptable um
but he angered a lot of people as well
when he
when he called it an ethnic mobilization
an ethnic mobilization and that is
because uh president zuma is a zulu he
attracts support from
uh zulu members of the ethnic group the
zulus in
south africa but a lot of a lot of
people who support zuma say this has got
nothing to do
with ethnic identity they think that
this is a
an issue of democracy they think that
jacob zuma has been forced into prison
as part of a political campaign to
marginalize him to to disempower him so
it's caused a lot of problems a lot of
difficulties in the ruling
anc party i think a lot of people a few
days ago were thinking that cyril
ramaphosa had
could handle this we're just going to
move back here to rambo pose ahead
in letting the courts deal with this
situation
and john legal experts suggesting that
jacob zuma's chances of success as slim
he's asked a constitutional court to
rescind his jail term if it doesn't go
his way
uh what of the escalation of a situation
there
look i think legally speaking i'd say
his his chances
are are less than slim of getting
himself out of jail he's
he's currently locked up he's serving uh
he'll serve about four months of a
15-month sentence
in durban on the east coast of south
africa there we go
a few people leaving leaving the shops
not sure if he was an employee or an
opportunist
but um look he's got very very little
hope of getting this sentence reversed
and it's just the first actually it's
the first legal action
of many that president zuma is
former president zuma is facing we're
going to walk down the
walk down what road again
so i think no i think that i think
legally speaking
i cannot see i don't think anybody can
really see jacob zuma getting out of
this one
he has employed a legal tactic a legal
strategy
that they call stalingrad here he fights
everything and he fights it
in multiple courts he fought the
decision of the constitutional court
uh he's um and that's what what that's
what we will hear from we'll get a
we should get a verdict from he's
basically challenging the okay
challenging the constitutional court
uh today very very unlikely to to get
out of that one and
it's going to be up to cyril ramaphosa
ultimately to defuse
this situation he's going to bring in
the military he's going to bring in the
south african
defense force but it's going to take
some serious political outreach
as well to you know to to bring
calm to the situation here because as
we've seen in alexandra the police
service they certainly cannot handle it